-Our next guest is an
Academy-Award nominated actress
you know from films such as
"Boys Don't Cry"
and "Queen and Slim"
and shows like
"Big Love"
and "American Horror Story".
She is starring in the second
isn't of Netflix's
"Russian Doll" and "The Girl
from Plainville,"
which is available
now on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-I have a great mom,
a great dad.
For the most part.
Great parents.
I have all my grandparents.
But I'm still depressed,
and one of them
is gonna pass away.
I don't know when, but...
when they do, I'm going to have
to be there for my parents,
to be there for my mom and dad
whenever their parents
pass away.
-Please welcome to the show,
Chloe Sevigny.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm so happy to have you here.
-Thank you.
I'm pleased to be here.
-This has been sort of a theme
for us this week,
but you also are one of these
people who were lucky enough
to have a pandemic baby.
-I do.
I have a pandemic baby, yes.
-Congratulations.
-Did you get him one of those
t-shirts, like,
"the pandemic ruined
my birthday?"
-Oh, no, but is he about
to turn two?
-He's about to turn two.
We're going to have his
christening.
-Oh, christening, okay.
-Because May is jam-packed
for us.
-Yeah.
-I'm getting married
at the end of May.
-Oh, congratulations.
-So I have, you know, his
birthday, bachelorette, wedding.
I was like, how many things can
I invite my friends to?
How many things will they
actually come out for us?
-That's true.
You got to kind of consolidate.
-Yes.
-Is he old enough --
is aware that he sort of maybe
missed some more parties than
he would have had at this point?
-Not yet, thank goodness, no.
Yes, I'm more like, you know,
everyone is like,
"Can you see that I'm smiling?"
He doesn't know anything
else but masks.
Masks have been his whole life.
-It's going to be amazing.
I think that people, you know,
obviously,
we're not gonna know for years
how it's actually affected kids,
but I think it's
going to be so exciting
when they're like, "Wait, people
have had this lower
half of their face
the whole time?"
Now, I associate you so much
with New York City,
and you've lived here
for over two decades, but yet,
you did not grow up
in the city,
and now you're going to have
a New York kid.
This is what I think about all
the time, having New York kids.
How do you feel about it so far?
What is it you want them to
discover about the city?
-I just love the neighborhoods
in the city.
And people always come
to New York
and they stay in Times Square,
which is fine.
But I'm like, you should go
and stay in little pockets.
-Yeah.
-And like, discover those
pockets and what's around.
Like, we go to local
bakery every day,
the local juice place.
Pepe Rosso is his favorite
restaurant.
He's like, "Pepe, Pepe, Pepe."
All he wants to do
is go to Pepe.
Everybody knows him there
and they pick him up.
And like, yes, we let them
pick him up.
-Yeah.
Perhaps we shouldn't.
Maybe we're not the best
parents, but...
-I think if you go to a place
like Pepe Rosso,
the expectation is someone's
going to pick up your kid.
[ Laughter ]
Have you had any of those --
you know, again,
because New York can also be,
I think just
parenting in general
can be stressful.
Have you had any of the moments
where you bring your kid out
in the world and you almost
hit a breaking point?
-Yes, actually, one of the first
times we brought him out,
I brought him to our local
playground, Vesuvio,
and there was a little
kid there who I could tell,
like, I already had a little bit
of a problem with this kid.
-Yeah.
-I was not so into this kid.
He was, like, maybe three,
and I was like,
this kid's got attitude.
There is something
about this kid.
And I had Vanja, my son,
on my lap like this,
and the kid throws
something at us.
It was like, this part
of a lock, like, a metal thing.
I was like [ Gasps ].
I didn't know
what I was going to do.
I was like,
do I yell at the kid?
Do I yell at the mom?
Do I yell at both of them?
I was losing my mind.
So I had to get up, walk out,
calm down, breathe,
and like call my sister-in-law
like, "What do I do?"
She was like, "you're gonna have
to see this woman
all the time at the playground.
You better not pick
a fight with her."
And I was like,
"What about the kid?
Can I pick a fight
with the kid?"
And now I see this kid walking
around on Prince Street.
And I'm like, this kid.
I got it out for this kid.
-Yeah. So, your son is over it,
but you're not?
-No.
-Every time you pass him,
you're like, "I know you.
I remember what you did."
So you have two amazing
shows out right now.
I want to talk about "Girl from
Plainville" real quick.
You're getting incredible
reviews, well deserved.
We're watching the show,
my wife and I.
It's very intense.
Based on a true story.
Was it an exciting role
to take on?
Because obviously, there is a
lot behind it.
-I mean, "exciting," I'm not
sure that's the right word.
But it's challenging,
and I watched the documentary
that our show is kind of based
on, "I Love You, Now Die."
I was very struck by the woman
they asked me to play.
Just her strength of character,
her resolve,
how soulful she was and how she
spoke about her son,
and how she really wanted people
to hear her son's story,
and that really propelled me to
get on board with the project.
And Elle Fanning is in it,
who I love and adore.
-Yeah, she's really
wonderful in it.
-I think she's got great taste
and she's an amazing actress,
and I think it's great for all
of her young fans to tune in
and really think about the way
they communicate via text.
It's so easy to read something
and just write
a flippant response,
but, you know,
we really have to consider.
-Yeah. You also to to --
I feel like, less challenging,
certainly, emotionally,
but you did have to do
a New England accident.
I will say, as a New Englander,
I thought you did
a very nice job.
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
I mean, it's one of those
ones that sticks out
like a sore thumb when it's not.
-I would think I'm pretty bad
at it, but, yes.
Yeah, I tried. I tried.
There is different levels of it
in the show,
so I think I kind of get away
with my minimal version.
-You did very nice job.
This is also very exciting.
"Russian Doll"
with Natasha Lyonne,
which is a show,
the first season I loved,
I was not alone in loving.
You've known Natasha forever.
Did you jump at the chance
to do season 2 with her?
-Yeah, of course.
I mean, I was in season 1.
One small, pivotal episode,
and she asked me to come back,
and I said, of course, I want to
hang out my my friends.
Who doesn't want to go to work
with their friends?
You know, you're my best friend.
You're hilarious.
You're fun to be around.
You're passionate.
I love your -- I love your show.
There was a lot of pressure
for the sophomoric effort.
-Yes, of course.
-You know, for the second
season, everybody's like,
is this going to be as good?
So it was very, like,
high stakes.
-And she also directed a lot.
As a friend, does she direct
well, knowing that you're
also her friend and not just
an actor in her show?
-Yeah, I mean -- yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You know, she can probably get
away with a few more things.
-Yeah.
-That I let slide.
I want to try and help her relax
into it, enjoy it,
and so maybe some of the
snapping was directed at me,
because I could take it.
-Yeah, that's true.
At the end of the day,
you guys had
the infrastructure in place
that she could maybe
be a little bit harder on you.
-That's right.
Just let it all out on me.
-I'm so excited to see that,
and congratulations again on
"Girl from Plainville."
It's really wonderful, and it's
so nice to have you here.
-Thank you so much.
-You guys, that's Chloe Sevigny.
Second season of "Russian Doll"
is streaming now on Netflix,
and new episodes of "The Girl
from Plainville"
air Tuesdays on Hulu.